make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so do you guys remember about a
week or so ago when Christian Bale was
announced for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and then like beta ray bill was
announced for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and everybody just kind of
connect to the dots and said Christian
Bale is gonna be playing beta ray bill
and and the the funny thing about it is
looking back I don't really know how we
got from A to B there was nothing to
indicate that Christian Bale was gonna
play beta ray bill right we just kind of
took this rumor and ran with it we were
just like Christian Bale's announced
beta evils announced there's no way use
a coincidence Christian Bale is playing
Barry Bill awesome you know we just kind
of ran with him and and call it a day
right well here's the thing I have it on
good authority and and it's kind of
weird I cannot phrase this as an
absolute fact right I have to freeze it
it's like speculation but I have it on
good authority that Christian Bale is
rumored I have to throw that in there to
be playing somebody other than beta ray
bill or Gore the god butcher he's not
playing either one right the
quote/unquote rumor the rumor is that
Christian Bale this is gonna blow
everyone's mind just like out was it
already the rumor quote-unquote is that
Christian Bale is on for three sees
three scenes right he's and talks for
three scenes in for four and he is
rumored to be playing Norman Osborn
oh how crazy is that right how crazy is
that
and here's a funny thing people would
respond and they would say no way
Christian Bale can play Norman Osborn
right no way you could play Norman
Osborn here's the thing man he can write
like like people I think a lot of people
who are really into comic books and
didn't really follow Christian Bale
before comic books are just kind of like
no man like I don't really see a guy who
played Bruce Wayne the way he did
playing and playing anybody like like
like Norman Osborn then enough I invite
you to go watch American Psycho if you
don't think that Christian Bale could
pull off a Norman Osborn do an American
Psycho will totally change your
perspective like that that movie is
amazing and Christian Bale could
probably pull it off right it's it's
it's pretty nuts like here's the thing I
mean like when you look at when you look
at Christian Bale from American Psycho
like what is he really but he's just
kind of like a crazy guy right and
that's one of the funny things is in the
movie
if I remember correctly and it's been
years since I saw but if I remember
correctly it was this idea that you
didn't really know what was going on was
actually happening or not right like did
he really beat up those chicks and he
really killed that one guy we don't
really know if those things were
actually happening right if he was just
hallucinating and going insane or if it
was actually taking place and I think it
ended on an ambiguous note although I'm
not 100% sure but like in that movie
essentially like his life is a sham
right like he talks about how like
basically he hates everybody around him
but he plays the part because it's his
job that's what he does when he's up you
know on Wall Street or whatever it is
you know but like literally he's living
a double life right there's the public
face of Christian Bale's character who I
think his name was Bateman there's the
public face which is like here's the
smile I put on for the world to see me
so I don't look insane and then there's
the insane side right like the crazy
side but if you go and look at American
Psycho it literally looks like you know
like the story of Norman Osborn like all
you have to do is inject some there
throw some situation in there where he's
injected with a green goblin formula
then goes insane and then basically ends
up fighting spider-man and that's
basically it
right cuz like Norman Osborn is almost
the exact same ways Christian Bale I
guess from a Christian Bale for American
Psycho but here's the funny thing about
it here's the big thing about it right
like if the MCU plays their cards right
if they do it correctly they could bring
in Dark Reign not exactly how they would
do it but it would be amazing if we got
Dark Reign
if we got Dark Reign and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe cuz you guys imagine
at an entire phase of just Dark Reign I
doubt we would get it it it may not
being like Civil War Wars just one movie
but like dark rain would be legit right
it would be one of the coolest things
ever flows you guys I don't know what
that is dark rain came out of a Civil
War and Secret Invasion you guys all
know about Civil War Captain America vs
Iron Man that kind of thing well of
course
Iron Man side ended up winning and the
result was that at the end of Civil War
Iron Man became the new director of
shield right that was his quote unquote
reward for having been successful in
implementing superhuman Registration and
so the result of that is you get a bunch
of things coming out of it right you get
the initiative and the initiative was
basically a story that dealt with the
fifty state initiative right that was
one of the big focal points of civil war
in the sense that it was like okay
superhumans have to be registered we
have to make sure that their their
powers are all registered with the
government so you know their identities
and so on and so forth so we can keep
track of them right and the idea was
there should be a superhero team in all
50 states that way every state is
covered by superheroes so if there's
like a crisis in San Francisco the
avengers don't have to jump in a Quinn
jet and travel from New York to San
Francisco hoping they get the
like there would already be superheroes
in in California although it is a pretty
massive state you need multiple
superhero teams which I think they did
but like there'd be a team they could
get there within like an hour or
something like that is instead of like
within like four hours because the Quinn
jet you know flies super fast but the
fact remains then after the events of
civil war you go into the initiative
then you go into the death of Captain
America and then you go into secret
invasion I really get house of him and
then you get Secret Invasion with Secret
Invasion dealt with the idea that the
scrolls had been secretly secretly
replacing superheroes all throughout the
entirety of earth in the Marvel Universe
right and so he didn't find out until
like the secret invasion event kicks off
but the scrolls have been doing it for a
long time and they did it because the
Illuminati right like Charles Xavier um
was a dr. strange
Iron Man Black Bolt of the Inhumans
Namor the Submariner
and I remember if Captain America was
part of the the Illuminati at that point
in time I don't think he was right I
think that was when when hickman went
back and changed things I think the
Captain America had already been booted
by them Doctor Strange had already wiped
his mind and then they sent him out of
the Illuminati after that but the
Illuminati ended up travelling to the
scroll homeworld and was like hey look
don't come messing with earth right
don't do anything with us you know we're
doing our own thing if you come over
here there's gonna be problems and the
scrolls basically kidnapped or knocked
him out copied their genes and then sent
them on their way with the Illuminati
being none the wiser of what was going
on so the Secret Invasion kicks off when
basically the scrolls had been like
going through and copying and making
duplicates of superheroes or at least
having themselves operated super kids of
superheroes and like Tony Stark is
director of shield didn't know he had no
clue that this was going on well the
intelligence community saw this it's
like a catastrophic failure of Tony
Stark like how could you be the head of
the most important intelligence
organization in the world and not know
right because shield taps into
everything right it taps into Interpol
it tapped in to mi6 it taps into the CIA
us the CIA the FBI the NSA like it's
haften of all the intelligence databases
the unidentified intelligence agencies
it taps into all of those right so like
it's a giant information gathering
resource and Stark didn't know and so
like in response to that he was kicked
out as director of shield and then like
at the end of sigrid invasion norman
osborn intercepted information that was
crucial to winning the war against the
scrolls which he used and it looked like
Norman Osborn was the one who had
basically gotten the victory for the day
so the result was that he was put in
charge as director of shield the first
thing he does is he immediately
dismantles it right he liked shuts down
shield and he's like done and now it's
hammer now it's my corporation right he
creates a like a cabal basically like
villains so you have like Loki
think you had Magneto I think he had
Emma Frost she had a few other people
here in there I came off top my head but
he had a cabal of villains Loki was a
chick at the time because that all came
out of J michael Straczynski Thor and
Loki stated chick for a while it was
kind of wild it was kind of weird but
nonetheless like it was one of these
things were like woman odds weren't it
basically taken over as director of
shield and then tried to conquer the
United States right so like the x-men
leave Westchester New York they end up
travelling to utopia which is this
island off the coast of San Francisco
they call it utopia but it's like this
little island of the coast of San
Francisco which becomes her new base of
operations like Norman Osborn like
invades a fantastic four building trying
to like you know take their technology
Franklin Richards because he could warp
reality he pulls out a toy gun and
shoots them with a real bullet but it's
crazy like it's crazy the kind of stuff
that goes on right like Dark Reign was
awesome but the overall gist is that
basically all the heroes had essentially
gone underground right during the Civil
War you had Captain America's Secret
Avengers well during Dark Reign all the
superheroes are basically Secret
Avengers right and so then you had like
bacon the son of Wolverine who played
Wolverine in the dark x-men bullseye who
played Hawkeye in the end the on the the
Dark Avengers like that's literally what
it was it was dark avengers dark x-men
it was awesome new Dark Reign is one of
the coolest landing initiatives of
Marvel ever did it was legit we could
get that with Christian Bale if he's
playing Norman Osborn right like we
could actually give that and it would be
pretty insane like it would be pretty
bonkers like I really want to see that
go down so I don't know let me know what
you guys think is here's here's the
thing here's the thing there is this
scoop about Christian Bale but then
there's also one about Black Adam and
the one about Black Adam will blow your
minds it is insane no one's ready for
black it's absolutely nuts ah yeah no
one's ready for a black Adam like if the
information that's been given to me is
correct
black Adam will be the best movie that
the DC Cinematic Universe has made so
far right like it'll be the absolute
best right like head and shoulders
it'll be on par with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so I guess we'll find
out but I think if you guys want to hear
that let me know like just leave comment
down below let me know and I'll spill
the beans on the info that I have about
what's going on with Black Adam but yeah
like this this is this is this is the
right I mean you know it's you know I
have to phrase it as it's rumored you
know I can't I cannot espouse it as an
absolute fact
but yeah Norman Osborn Christian Bale
seems like a pretty good mix to me but
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explain make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
Rob cork if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]